for the first time large tour groups of
south koreans allowed into the blue
house to see where all their presidents
have lived and worked until now
there will be people for and against it
but as i come to see for myself the
compound is very spacious as the
official presidential residence it's
always had the tightest security
now cameras are welcome in what is
historically the heart of seoul this
part of seoul has traditionally been the
seat of government the blue house is
located right next to gyeongbok palace
home to generations of korean kings
moving the presidential office from here
appends six hundred years of tradition
and causes major upheaval in the way the
city works
that upheaval put off previous
presidents from even attempting it but
not newcomer yunsukyo
considering the inconvenience to the
people and complete return of the blue
house i thought it would be right to
make a prompt decision
it's not been easy
yoon moved his office to the defense
ministry building in the far more
congested yongsan area of the city and
took over the official residence of the
foreign minister to live in provoking
widespread public criticism
it meant at the time of his inauguration
he had the lowest approval rating of any
new president but a week they say is a
long time in politics the congestion
from presidential motorcades has not
been as bad as residents feared and some
people near the new office even say it's
good for business
many more people from out of the town
will come here and it'll be good for the
neighborhood
and there's a sense the blue house now
belongs not to one incumbent president
but to all
it really feels like this large piece of
land should be returned to the people
i think the president is putting an end
to authoritarian practices there's never
been anything like this
right at the start of his term yoon may
have just found one of his first
controversial decisions has already
earned him a small place in history rob
mcbride al jazeera seoul